hallo leute sie teure mal waren heute
genau auf den tag es ist ein jahr her
seit ich den amazon surprise
adventskalender ausgepackt habe und
dieses video hat in der zeit 1,3
millionen aufrufe bekomme 1,3 millionen
aufrufe das müsst ihr euch mal
vorstellen das sind über eine million
menschen die wissen wollten was in dem
amazon surprise adventskalender drin wir
sind ungefähr 80 millionen menschen in
deutschland sind ganz schön viele
menschen hier los und mir ist das gar
nicht aufgefallen dass ich post von
amazon bekommen haben die mir dieses
jahr den kalender oder verziehen
zugeschickt haben das war wohl ihrer art
danke zu sagen für 1,3 millionen auf
besteck und bezahlte werbung hat gut für
amazon funktioniert und ich weiß es ist
oktober bis zum ersten dezember ist es
noch ziemlich weit hin aber auf youtube
gehört das mittlerweile zum guten ton so
früh wie möglich diese bands kalender
videos zu drehen und das machen wir das
design ist auf jeden fall hübsch
erinnert mich von dem vom letzten jahr
aber dieses mal gibt es die produkte und
kein food das macht mich ein bisschen
traurig aber es ist hier nummer eins ok
wisst ihr was hätte mir sagen dass das
nicht praktisch ist ein offenes angebot
haargummis drei von diesen ringel
haargummis finde ich sehr gut ich
verliere sie viel zu oft türchen nummer
zwei ist so aufregend aus liebe
weihnachtszeit ihr wisst es was ist das
das ist ein kleiner apfel okay das ist
echt süß einen lippenbalsam am ende ist
natürlich die frage ist dieser
adventskalender wirklich auch sein geld
wert
ich kann es noch nicht einschätzen wie
diesem moment erlebe ich auch meinen job
box nummer drei das hat jetzt eine probe
der einheit 24plus face cream gab es
nicht letztes mal
das war beim immobilien wenn es können
denn so eine erklärung was sie drin wäre
wäre schon gut eine creme probe ok fia
komm zu mir
ja groß ist anders ich kenne mich
tatsächlich nicht so mit dem beauty
kalendern auch dass man dafür größen
kriegt aber für 50 euro
reisende sind noch weil klebt so die
stube also das ist so glaube das macht
man so dicht wie cocktail kirschen gott
sieht dass schnell ein
regel nummer fünf baumann ich hätte so
gern was zu essen sleek make up also ein
matter lippenstift von smeet die marke
habe ich schon mal gehört ich habe sie
noch nicht ausprobiert und die farbe
gefällt mir sehr gut wurde das ist eine
ganze größe sehr gut nummer sechs
nikolaus natürlich ein großes paket
finde ich echt gute produkte city flash
conditioner wimpern spülung ist dass
leute ich hab doch schon ein sehr
rutschig
das ist sehr viel jetzt muss ich mal
wirklich mal schauen ob es sich gelohnt
hat das kostet 39 95 der adventskalender
kostet 49 95 das bedeutet nur wenn man
das holen möchte kann man sich den
adventskalender besorgen und dann ist
das gut ich verstehe das nicht kalt ist
will jetzt wisst ihr warum ich kein
youtube nummer 7 nach dem verschwinden
serum kommt jetzt l'oréal men expert
leute warf ihr körper gesicht und haare
ja ich kenne bestimmt ein kerl den ich
das geben kann also warum solltest du
dein beauty adventskalender wo es
eigentlich um makeup und somit scheiß
geht männer produkt reinpacken
es macht gar keinen sinn macht wenn man
den ausgepackt hat kann man den umdrehen
dann entwickelt sich neuer trendlabs
etwa ein lied pampa man muss das zeug
zweimal am tag benutzen für 30 tage und
man soll auf punkte lippen haben ich
meine ich habe schon sehr volle lippen
das weiß ich ist das gesund hat das
jemand schon von euch mal ausprobiert
und besser funktioniert nummer 9 richtig
forming shower gel schaum ist heute noch
nasenbären boxing macht kann ich nicht
auf meinem schelde bringen
wenn ich auf meinem channels de mehr
videos bringe meckern mich die leute die
meckern eh schon so viel woher ist das
gekommen dass man plötzlich mir soviel
reinredet und sagen möchte wie ich etwas
tun soll zum beispiel drei cocktails die
ballern ich schneide es schon seit dem
ersten mal so wie ich es schneide viel
editing viele - viele weise nächsten
motion dinger und so und das macht mir
halt mega spaß und ich für diese videos
so lustig und mini faces so vielen da
draußen gefällt und dass sie halt auch
echt oft aufgerufen werden aber trotzdem
nach so vielen folgen schreiben wir dann
leute nächstes mal bitte weniger editing
okay ich notiere mir das tut mir leid
das ist so will editing war
ich weiß nicht ich bin ein herr
bibliothek channel deswegen sind jetzt
wieder happy und machten beauty nummer
10 wieder supreme was
es riecht sehr toxisch wir gucken jetzt
einmal nach das ding ist 15 euro wert
was macht dann dieses spiel ist entfernt
fältchen innerhalb einer stunde glättet
und strafft die haut das beauty
geheimnis der star ich bin ein star und
ich hab davor noch nicht gehört habe es
ein geheimnis ist okay nächste station
ist die ma 11 was ist das das wollte ich
immer schon war haben weil ich das immer
bei dm sehen das ist nämlich für die
hände
das ist eine ganz normale creme aber sie
hat er diesen typischen eos luxus die
gleich philipp balsam rausbringt die es
wirklich hammer wir sind in der hälfte
durch herr doktor zwei phasen thermo
conditioner es sofort pflege mit
hitzeschutz thank you das habe ich
wirklich gebraucht aber heute habe ich
werde sie gerade wieder gelockt und
dachte mir ich hab nix mehr von meiner
arbeit
es riecht einfach frisch gewaschen weil
sie nicht kenne
der kalender ist auf jeden fall für
jemanden der sie soll ich noch nicht so
mit produkten aus kennen beziehungsweise
was es so alles auf dem markt gibt und
das ist eine gute chance so mal ein paar
neue sachen auszuprobieren wie zum
beispiel hitzeschutz ich glaube nicht
dass jeder weiß was ein hitzeschutz ist
oder das ist wichtig ist ein hitzeschutz
zu benutzen und das hilft das gut weiter
das riecht nach rosmarin kartoffeln weil
auch rosmarin da drin ist
es riecht auf jeden fall luxuriös 28
euro für 450 milliliter so ein zehntel
ist es junge öffnete probe das muss man
wirklich super schön waschen damit ich
28 berufener seite ausleben kirche
nummer 14
die gute alte kneip creme aromapflege
dusche lebensfreude mach es riecht so
zitronig nee superschön eine pflege
dusche ein bisschen klein 15
ich wollte sagen wann kommt was für die
vegane bio grüntee suchmaske hall wir
sind bei der 16
ein gutschein amazon uk erhalten sie 5
euro rabatt auf alle luchse review die
produkte die auf amazon luxury beauty zu
finden sind ja hier in fünf euro
gutschein ist schon nett aber ja 17
eine kleine tour vital ist laser mal
drei macht es wieder etwa meine falten
weg ich hasse meine zeiten was sag ich
leute die masken die sind im trend
oh gott was habe ich schon mal ich habe
es geliebt und ich weiß es nicht aber es
sind so kleine masken stücke und die
sind jetzt im rosenblatt design und er
legt man die sicherheit so auf die
stellen wo man halt meint das ist eine
maske gut tun würde
ich fand das total cool aber wie gesagt
es ist wieder eine verpackung für einmal
und ja aber lasst uns gar nicht in diese
richtung gehen das ist jetzt aus korea
alles was aus korea an die brocken kommt
funktioniert auch ich fand auch sehr gut
schloss hat meine poren auch verfeinert
19 u 19 ist schwer von frei
alfresco exklusiv in apotheken und bei
amazon
was ist schön
es ist für ganze haut das erste
experiment nimmt ganz neue ausmaße an
ich glaube das ist super gut wie tot us
richter hat es so hochwertig oh mein
gott nummer 20 gelitten
sonst liegt um ein grad ich hab noch nie
teil einer für silvester sind glitter
eyeliner perfekt okay wir ja nicht so
viel farbe dir gibt man kann ja
nachziehen muss stelle ich mir aber ganz
cool vor wenn man es so sich dann noch
ein bisschen glitzer ins auge macht ist
jetzt aber nicht das produkt was ich
finde was unbedingt hier rein muss dass
ich nämlich gut finde ist dass ich das
gefühl dass dieses konzept eher in die
richtung geht pflege und innere
schönheit ein bisschen hervorholen
anstatt hat mehr drauf zu legen
an make-up und jetzt ein glitzer
eyeliner findig fällt jetzt ein bisschen
heraus 21
seht ihr da brauch ich geredet einen
lippenpflegestift mit sonnenschutzfaktor
das habe ich da drin erwartet da hat
mich amazon nicht enttäuscht danke 22 ja
ich habe überall diesen pinsel gesehen
und wollte unbedingt diese pinsel habe
experience ihrer branche ja ich habe
keinen konzil abbrechen ich weiß nicht
warum alle beauties schweren
mittlerweile darauf meine
maskenbildnerin hatte letztens auch
diese pinsel und ich mag sie einfach ich
mag es wie sie aussehen ich mag
gefühle sind einfach richtig tolle
pinsel nummer 23 einen tag vor
weihnachten heiligabend fällt das ist
ein parfüm proben perfekte location von
babor ich glaube war wo er ist eine sehr
teure marke behandlungs gutschein im
wert von 10 euro kommen sie denn
behandeln das ok es wirkt als ob man das
glas kaputt machen müsste
wirkstoffkonzentrat für müde haut mit
fehlende ausstrahlung es tut mir leid
aber sie haben eine fehlende
ausstrahlung ist schon ein bisschen zu
heftig für mich bin noch nicht so tief
dieser die welt dass ich irgendwelche
polen auf platzen lasse und dann ist
zunächst level shit und wir kommen zum
allerletzten pack wir müssen uns jetzt
mal ein bisschen vorstellen es ist
heiligabend mann wachte auf man weiß wo
heute ist viel los sehr viel stress und
jetzt hole ich erst mal mein letztes
päckchen aus meinem adventskalender
lehre bis aden magen
es fühlt sich wirklich an wie
weihnachten meine mutter schenkt mir
jedes jahr lieber bis abend produkte es
ist wirklich witzig gerade es ist
wirklich hart
ich weiß das ist von 11 bis abend gibt
es so eine art mauer screen darauf
schwört meine maskenbildnerin weil man
sie einfach über halten schmieren kann
und sie ist super gut
ich hatte aber noch nie ein elisabeth
adendorf rem green peace and grey
wollten sie schon immer mal nach grünen
thärichen hier haben sie das innere des
abend greenpeace hairspray wir gehen es
mein freund ich finde dieser dürft
funktioniert gut für den frühling und
frisch nun nach grünen thärichen möchte
das land studiert leser bis arten krieg
soll ich euch mal was sagen wenn ihr
eure mama dieses jahr richtig schöne
freude machen wollte und vielleicht ein
paar geschwister ab mit denen jetzt
zusammen legen könnt dann würde ich mir
überlegen den für sie zu ich meiner mama
kann ich das nicht schenken weil sie
wahrscheinlich zugeguckt hat hallo
sie weiß schon was drin ist wenn man
eine etwas jüngere schwester oder so hat
dass man so ein einstieg in die beauty
welt geben kann mit so ein paar
produkten wie hitzeschutz spray oder
pflegeöl dass man halt so ein bisschen
mit auf den weg gibt hier achte mal ein
bisschen auf die sprünge ich mal mit
grünen tee voll zu dem preis kann man
nicht viel sagen 50 euro passt es sind
viel mehr produkte drin in einem viel
größeren wert als 50 euro da kann man
jetzt wirklich nicht gegen meckern auch
wenn 50 euro viel geld sind aber da muss
man sich einfach selber entscheiden ist
es einem das wert oder nicht da bleibe
ich komplett neutral
ansonsten hoffe ich dass euch das video
sehr gut gefallen hat dass es jetzt
nicht zu lang ist und ich euch nicht
langweile arbeitet wisst ihr was jetzt
hat das spaß gemacht ich habe eine menge
neuer produkte durch ausprobieren kann
in meiner beauty reihe
ich bin sehr gespannt wie ihr euch der
erste teil gefallen hat und bald kommt
jetzt der zweite teil von dem beauty
experiment ich finde sehr lustig ich mag
das total und
ja ich bin jetzt gerade nicht drin denn
hier die lampen ich drehe und das
leuchtet dann komisch und gibt mir
umdenken daumen nach oben schreibt mir
welches gelände ihr euch dieses jahr
holt ich werde dieses jahr auf jeden
fall noch einen eigenen basteln das hab
ich mir ganz fest vorgenommen denn ich
liebe es eigener des geländers nichts
macht mir mehr spaß als einfach leuten
eine freude zu machen wir zum kleinen
adventskalender deswegen wenn ihr mich
jetzt freund habe da nicht alles wir
sehen uns beim
gerade zwei meter vom juli video ich
hoffe ihr euch hat das gefährliche sich
gerade so unglaublich gut meine haare
riechen fresh gewicht grüntee meine
hände riechen nach creme meine
fingernägel riechen nach marzipan view
die bahn und ich sage es genug auf
meinem arsch
[Musik]